corona chaos an unseren schulen so war
es ja schon im frühjahr als die schulen
flächendeckend bundesweit geschlossen
waren monatelang selbst dann als schon
modelle in deutschland wieder geöffnet
hatten jetzt wieder corona chaos an
unseren schulen zum zweiten mal und
diesmal ist es quarantäne chaos es gibt
keine klaren keine einheitlichen regeln
darüber wer in quarantäne muss bedeutet
hunderttausende schüler und schülerinnen
wieder raus aus dem unterricht
unterrichtsausfall und es gibt
vielerorts nach wie vor keine
funktionierenden hygiene konzepte in den
klassenzimmern da verspielt die
regierung im moment ihr vertrauen in der
korona krise und die familien die barden
genau hier die fehler der deutschen
corona politik direkt in ihrem alltag
aus der erfolg der korona politik der
entscheidet sich jetzt in den schulen